Все ще занадто багато людей, які не можуть зрозуміти, що Росія повинна і буде переможена на полі бою.
Я був би шокований, якби після війни ми побачили Лаврова чи Путіна на міжнародних заходах.
Це булa б, власне, зрада.
Нам потрібно повернути мільйони біженців додому в Україну.
Україна звільнить Крим до кінця літа, до серпня 2023 року.
Для мене Крим все більше виглядає як пастка для російських військ.
Генерале Ходжес, дякую, що долучилися до програми.
Вже десять місяців триває гострий конфлікт у Європі.
Чи не час НАТО визначитися з тим, які її стратегічні цілі у цій війні?
Я думаю, це влучне запитання. Ми говорили про важливість того,
щоб Україна не програла і щоб Росія не виграла.
Але мені здається, що ми не проголосили, якою саме є кінцева стратегічна мета.
Це мало би бути повне відновлення суверенітету України на всій її території,
включаючи Крим,
повернення депортованих українців, особливо 200 тисяч українських дітей, які були викрадені та вивезені до Росії.
Такі речі слід прояснити.
І чому їх не прояснюють?
Я не впевнений, чесно.
Мене розчарувало небажання прояснити, так би мовити, на 5 відсотків шляху, якою є наша мета.
Я думаю, це має декілька потенційних пояснень.
Стурбованість щодо ескалації, яка, на мою думку, була переоцінена.
У європейських столицях і у Вашингтоні все ще занадто багато людей, які не можуть зрозуміти,
що Росія повинна і буде переможена на полі бою.
І я думаю, що є занепокоєння щодо наслідків відносин з Китаєм та іншими зовнішніми гравцями.
Чи можна припустити, що цілі НАТО десь у майбутньому розійдуться з цілями України?
Ми бачили, як канцлер Шольц говорив про повернення Європи до довоєнного мирного порядку з Росією
та вирішення всіх питань спільної безпеки. Це насправді реально?
Важко уявити, що найближчим часом ми повернемося до звичних справ із Росією.
Точно не з нинішнім керівництвом і не з більшістю інших відомих осіб у Кремлі.
Ми не знаємо, що буде після поразки Росії.
Я думаю, що, безперечно, є багато обґрунтованих аналізів,
які розглядають можливість або розпаду Російської Федерації, або зміни того, хто там керує.
Я не відстоюю жоден з цих сценаріїв, але я думаю, що ми маємо бути відкритими
та думати про можливості та наслідки.
Але я не можу собі уявити, що через кілька тижнів чи місяців після завершення цього конфлікту
все стане, як було завжди.
Російська держава буде завжди. Є і, звичайно, буде. І завжди повинна бути російська держава.
І нам потрібно буде працювати з ними щодо всіх вагомих питань, які нині для нас важливі.
Але я вважаю, що наголос має бути зроблено на захисті міжнародного порядку,
який включає безумовну повагу до кордонів, повагу до міжнародного права, повагу до прав людини.
І ми також повинні зосередитися на тому, щоб підняти Україну економічно,
тому що нам потрібно повернути мільйони біженців додому в Україну.
І нам також потрібно допомогти Україні знову почати виробляти зерно та експортувати зерно,
яке потрібне мільйонам людей в Африці та Азії.
Але тут не може бути жодних плескань по спині та рукостискань,
мовляв, нехай минуле залишиться в минулому.
Треба розглянути питання воєнних злочинів, а також репарацій. Чи це оминуть, як Ви думаєте?
Ні, зовсім ні. Я був у Міжнародному кримінальному суді кілька тижнів тому,
і я впевнений, що зараз вони роблять багато важкої роботи,
готуючи справи за воєнні злочини кремлівського керівництва,
зокрема щодо цих депортацій українських дітей,
геноциду та щоденні атаки на електромережі та цивільні цілі.
Це все воєнні злочини. І тому я не можу собі уявити,
я був би шокований, якби після завершення цього конфлікту
ми побачили міністра закордонних справ Лаврова, президента Путіна
чи будь-кого з нинішнього керівництва РФ на міжнародних заходах.
Це булa б, власне, зрада.
Я маю на увазі, що проти всіх цих людей будуть проводитися розслідування
та висунуті звинувачення у воєнних злочинах.
Я маю на увазі, виходячи з того, що вони говорять публічно і що ми всі спостерігаємо щодня.
Тож мені буде цікаво простежити за цим.
Щодо репарацій, то, звичайно, я думаю, що Росія повинна буде взяти на себе певну відповідальність,
щоб допомогти оплатити відновлення України.
Але, знаєте, у мене завжди є невеликі проблеми з репараціями,
тому що зазвичай, як ми бачимо після Першої світової війни та Другої світової війни та в інших війнах,
ці репарації також можуть мати негативний бік.
Той факт, що сьогодні Польща вимагає репарацій у розмірі 1,3 трильйона євро
від свого партнера по НАТО і ЄС Німеччини, є проявом цього.
Тому я більше зосереджений на воєнних злочинах, ніж на репараціях.
Але, звичайно, Росія повинна буде понести частину витрат на відновлення України.
Генерале Ходжес, як довго Захід може підтримувати Україну на нинішньому рівні?
Влітку в одному з повідомлень з Донбасу, коли там точилися інтенсивні бої,
йшлося, що за два дні Росія витратила більше боєприпасів, ніж мала в своєму арсеналі вся британська армія.
Так, ми багато дізналися або нам це нагадало про те, що потрібно для безперервних наземних боїв.
Витрати боєприпасів, особливо кількість загиблих, втрати техніки та авіації - це все вражає.
І тому всім нам доводиться переоснащувати нашу оборонну промисловість
і шукати способи протидіяти цій масі, яку залучила Росія.
Нам не обов’язково протистояти цій масі масою.
Насправді точність може перемогти масу, якщо у вас достатньо високоточної зброї.
І я відчуваю, що ми будемо дотримуватися цього.
Ви знаєте, звичайно, нещодавно з Пентагону надійшли повідомлення про те,
що Білий дім має намір схвалити поставку систем протиракетної оборони Patriot в Україну.
Це важливий крок Білого дому, тому що вони дорогі, і їх у нас небагато.
Тож той факт, що Білий дім робить це, є дуже обнадійливим знаком.
І президент сказав про це.
Завершилися проміжні вибори у США, і він має сильну підтримку обох партій для продовження цієї допомоги Україні.
І я думаю, що Конгрес та адміністрація визнають, що йдеться не лише про Україну,
а йдеться про міжнародний порядок, заснований на правилах.
Ідеться про стабільність і безпеку в Європі, що важливо для американського процвітання,
тому що наше процвітання залежить від європейського процвітання.
І, нарешті, йдеться про стримування Китаю, китайці спостерігають,
чи можемо ми об’єднатися і допомогти Україні перемогти Росію.
Протягом останніх десяти місяців Росія зображала цю війну в багатьох різних формах,
але часто як війну між Росією та Заходом.
Ви вірите, що рано чи пізно війна між Заходом і Росією може стати неминучою?
Ні. Насправді, мені здається, що Україна досягла незворотного імпульсу,
що Росія не може відкотити це назад.
І навіть президент Зеленський сказав, що, мовляв, мені війська не потрібні.
Мені потрібні інструменти, обладнання, амуніція тощо.
І тому я думаю, що шлях, яким ми зараз йдемо,
поки Захід зберігає зґуртованість і виконує все, що обіцяв, і надалі збирається виконувати, зберігаючи санкції,
це не обов’язково призведе до конфлікту за участю НАТО безпосередньо проти Росії.
Але ключове - це ми, чи ми всі будемо триматися разом.
Нині Кремлю потрібен цей наратив.
Я маю на увазі, що вони мають пояснювати своєму населенню,
чому ця військова спецоперація обернулася для них такою катастрофою,
тому що сказати, що нас розчавлює Україна, було б дуже важко.
Тому їм потрібно якось виправдати те, що вони роблять зі своїм власним населенням,
розширивши наратив, сказавши, що це Росія проти НАТО.
Чи можу я Вас запитати: де буде ця війна через 12 місяців?
Не там, де Ви хотіли б, а куди, на Вашу думку, вона насправді переміститься?
Чудове запитання. Моя оцінка така, що Україна звільнить Крим до кінця літа, до серпня 2023 року.
Я не знаю, скільки Донбасу буде все ще частково окуповано.
Я думаю, що більшість людей, які живуть на тих так званих сепаратистських територіях,
насправді воліли би бути частиною України, а не Росії.
Але ключовим найбільш вирішальним тереном, якщо хочете, є Крим.
Україна ніколи не буде в безпеці, поки Росія незаконно окуповує частину Криму.
Тому я вірю, що до кінця літа Україна цього досягне.
Ще занадто рано планувати парад перемоги,
але безперечно буде багато місяців важких боїв.
Росіяни продовжуватимуть атакувати цивільні цілі в надії продовжити цей конфлікт,
щоб змусити нас втратити волю.
Але я не думаю, що це станеться.
Ми знаємо, що війна - це випробування волі, і очевидно,
що українські солдати та український народ мають більшу волю,
ніж російське населення та російські солдати.
Тож це питання логістики. А російська логістична система дуже крихка і під величезним тиском.
Український генеральний штаб робить дуже якісну роботу,
завдаючи ударів по російській логістиці
та тому, що ми називаємо лініями зв’язку - по основним шляхам постачання.
До Криму ведуть лише дві дороги.
Одна - це Керченський міст, який вже сильно пошкоджений.
А ще є так званий наземний міст, який пролягає через Маріуполь і Мелітополь.
Українці вже вразили цей важливий міст та Мелітополь.
Отже, вони вже завдають шкоди, порушуючи два сухопутні шляхи, які ведуть до Криму.
І для мене Крим все більше виглядає як пастка для російських військ.
Генерале Ходжес, щиро дякую.